欢迎来到书卷声播
今天我们要来跟你一起深入剖析一份
很特别的资料
它不是书
也不是什么研究报告
而是一位在市场打滚超过15年
名叫巨人节的资深交易者
在一场演讲里分享的重点笔记
你可以把它想象成
就是一位市场老手
把他用无数真实交易换来的体物
浓缩成了十个核心观念
没错
而且我们这次的任务
我觉得要先讲清楚
不是要给你什么一页自负的名牌
那也不是这份笔记的重点
我们的目标是从这些观念中
为你体炼出一套可以带走
而且能真正内化成自己系统的
一个思考框架
对 思考框架
我觉得这个词用得很好
这更像是一次思维上的升级
好 那我们就直接切入核心
这份笔记啊
他开头就抛出一个非常犀利
甚至我会觉得有点冒犯的问题
就是说
你在市场上听到的那些大诗
那些故事
可信吗
这个问题很直接
超直接
讲者巨人节的观点就是
少听故事
多看对账单
他甚至提到
主办单位还核对过他近五年
累积下来达到兆等级的成交记录
这个开场很震撼
但也点出了一个关键
就是他敢进行这么大量的交易
背后的核心逻辑其实只有一个
就是他建立的这套系统
长期运作下来的期望值
必须是正的
期望值是正的
对
这句话很重要
他直接把交易从一次性的那种赌博
拉高到可重复执行的生意这个层次
我觉得生意这个词用得真好
做生意不会指望每一笔都赚钱
但你会去算你的毛利成本
确保长期下来是盈利的
完全正确
所以这就是我们今天要探讨的第一个核心
你真正该追求的是一个数学上
期望值为正的系统
而不是去执着单一次交易的成败
一到你建立起这个观念
很多市场上的杂音
你就可以自动过滤掉了
好
那既然交易是一门生意
这门生意的底层逻辑是什么
很多人都觉得交易很神秘
好像需要什么独门的武功秘籍
对 大家都想找秘籍
但讲者认为
你跟那些能赚到上亿元的大户
差别通常不在于资讯落差
而在于逻辑 经验 还有转换能力
然后所有逻辑的核心
其实就五个字
供需不平衡
没错
他把一个看似超复杂的金融市场
还原到了最原始的商业原理
这点我觉得真的非常高明
他在笔记里用了一个极其生动的比喻
台风那个对不对
就是台风
这个台风的比喻我印象超深刻
他说你不会等到气象局都发布路上警报了
才开始去市场抢购蔬菜
专业的人是在台风还在几千公里外的太平洋上行程时
就开始规划了
台风过后
蔬菜的供给因为浓损了急剧下降
但大家的需求不变
价格自来就容易上涨
这就是最纯粹的供需失衡
而且他还进一步延伸这个比喻
他提到记忆体的例子
这几年因为AI伺服器的需求
根本是爆炸性成长
这就是需求端的剧烈变化
但同时上游的制造商
因为前几年的市场不好
纷纷减产或调整产能
这就造成了供给端的收缩
所以一边强力拉动
一边供给又紧缩
哇 这就创造了一个巨大的
可以预期的不对等
所以说 真正的专业教育者
他们的研究是坐在新闻头条出现之前的
没错
他们不是在追逐各价格
而是在寻找未来可能发生的那个失衡点
是的
他们脑中已经设计好各种剧本了
如果台风陆镜片了 没登陆
那我的避险策略是什么
如果台风真的来了 而且是强台
那我该如何放大我的战果
这才是专业的思维
对 好
了解了这个供需不平衡的核心逻辑后
下一个问题就是
那我要去哪里找这些机会呢
这里笔记提到一个
我觉得会让很多人
啊哈一声的观点
就是很多能赚钱的东西
你早就知道
只是你从来没把它变成
可以执行的策略
这点真的很有趣
它基本上是在说
黄金就散落在你每天经过的路上
只是你把它们当成了普通的石头
它举了三个例子
把我们习以为常的新闻废话
变成实际的赚钱流程
第一个就是新春行情
哦
这个每年都在讲
简直是每年农历年前财经新闻的固定栏目听到都会背了但讲者提出的挑战是你真的有动手去验证过吗没错他的意思不是叫你盲目相信
新春行情一定会涨这件事
而是把它当成一个代验证的假说
动手把你自己的持股清单拿出来
一档一档地去回撤过去十年
如果在封关前一周买进
开红盘后一周卖出
胜率到底有多高
报酬率怎么样
对
然后你会不会发现
这个策略在某些特定产业
效果特别好
但在电子股上却不怎么样
这背后的思维
就是将被动接收的公共资讯
转化成自己可以验证
可以执行的私有策略
是的
它挑战的是我们那种
听完就算了的关心
而且你甚至不需要会写程式
只要有耐心动手去一笔一笔统计
就能建立起一个策略的出行了
第二个例子
是大家常在新闻上看到的融资大件
这个我知道
通常大家看到这个标题反应就是散户断头了
然后开始在旁边吃瓜看戏
对幸灾乐化嘛
但讲者看到的不是戏
而是一个潜在的进场条件
他把这个很模糊的概念
变得非常具体
例如你可以设定一个筛选条件
找出今天融资减幅排行榜的前10名
但这样还不够
因为你可能会买在下跌的半山腰
所以它再加上第二个滤网
融资维持率低于130%
等一下
是个融资维持率低于130%的条件
很有意思
这等于是说
你不只要找散户在卖的股票
你还要找那些已经被
被逼到墙角
快要断气的股票
因为维持率低于130%
就代表面临追缴保证金的压力
那个卖压可以说是
宣泄到最极致的时刻了
你完全抓到精髓了
这时候反人可能是反转的起点
对
这就是把一个模糊的市场情绪
量化成两个
可以严格执行的筛选条件
这就是从看热闹
变成找门道
那第三个例子就更直接了
叫做成交量破记录
当市场出现15年前的
巨大成交量时
大部分人的反应就是惊叹
哇 今天量好大
市场好热
然后就没有然后了
对 就没了
但他的思考路径完全不同
他会立刻问一个最根本的问题
在这种情况下
谁是确定无疑
直接受益的人
答案非常明显啊
券商
那是一种化繁为简的思考方式
因为大部分人看到天亮
脑中想的都是超复杂的问题
这是高档出货量
还是换手量
指数会不会反转
对啊
都在猜
那他的思路是
绕开这些难以预测的问题
去找出最直接
最不会错的受益者
正是如此
他说买进券商股
最差的情况就是
市场对这个题材没反应
股价不动
那你设个停损点出场就好啦
但如果市场开始联想
认为这种高档量能会变成一种常态
那券商股的本益比就有可能被重新估值
这就是潜在的巨大获利空间
这是一个风险相对有限
但潜在回报很高的交易
是的
你这样一讲我才发现
这三个例子的共通点
就是把大家习以为常
甚至当成杂讯的东西
重新赋予了策略上的意义
这才是真正的嫁及所在
没错
这就是他强调的那个转换能力
资讯本身是公平的
人人都能看到
但你能不能把它转换成自己的优势
这就是高手跟一般人的区别
所以我们有了供需失衡的核心逻辑
也知道怎么把公开资讯变成策略
但最难的往往是下一步
实际下单
这份笔记对于执行这一块
有提到一个我觉得会颠覆很多人
想象的观点
是的
他直接挑战了很多人
奉为归捏的技术分析
他并不是说
技术分析完全没用哦
而是警告我们不要滥用
尤其是在极短线的交易里面
他说短线越短
越不要用技术分析去硬解释
这句话很重
非常重
我记得他举了一个
记忆体报价的例子
假设某个记忆体的现货报价
连续大涨了好几天
市场气氛非常狂热
相关的股票也天天涨停
但就在某一天
报价的涨幅突然趋缓
注意不是下跌
不是跌
只是涨得变慢了
对
可能只是从前一天的涨4%变成今天的持平股价都可可能瞬间从涨停打到跌停。这就是他所谓的资讯触发事件改变了供需预期。
真正驱动价格崩跌的,
不是因为K线跌破了哪一条均线,
而是市场上最敏感的那群人,
从报价涨幅趋缓这个微小的资讯中,
解读出最强的动能可能已经过去了。
于是供需平衡瞬间逆转。
对,就导致了践踏式的卖压
所以事后你当然可以用技术分析去解释
说这里出现了什么乌云罩顶
跌破了五日线支撑
但那都是后见之名嘛
在为已经发生了价格找理由而已
没错
所以他才说的那句更重的话
放下对K线的执着是你进步的关键
这提醒我们要去寻找价格波动背后的真音
而不是只拿着锤子
看什么都是钉子
好 这点非常发人深深
接下来这个观念我认为
可能是今天整个分享里
最重要也最反直觉的一个
就是关于胜率和风险报酬比的探讨
这个确实是核心中的核心
绝大多数人包括我自己
在刚进入市场时
都会陷入一个迷思
疯狂追求高胜率
没错
都梦想成为那种百发百中
从不失手的股神
对啊
大家想的都是怎么把胜率
从50%提升到55%
再从55%提升到60%
但讲者指出
这是一条非常艰辛
而且天花板很低的路
你可能要花上好几年的努力
才能提升那微不足道的5%
而且胜率的极限
很难超过70%
但是他提醒我们
回归到交易期望值的
那个数学公式上
期望值等于
胜率乘以平均获利
减掉赔率乘以平均亏损
对,这里面有两个变数可以优化
一个是胜率
另一个就是赚钱时赚多少
vs赔钱时赔多少的比例
也就是风险报酬币
没错
等一下,这跟一般我们听到的很不一样
所以它的意思是
就算我十次交易只对了三次
胜率只有30%
但只要那三次赚得够多
亏损的七次亏得够少
长期下来我还是能大获全胜
你完全理解了
他认为
与其痛苦的去追求
那看得到天花榜的胜率
不如把绝大部分心力
放在那个可以无限拉开的
风险报酬比上
他说
胜率的上限是100%
但风险报酬比的提升
是无限的
无限的
你可以做到赔100万
但赚1亿
这才是交易真正的放大器
真正的精髓所塞
这就解释了
为什么我们常常听到
那些传奇交易员的故事
他们可能一年只出售几次
甚至很多次交易都是小赔收场
但只要抓住一次大的趋势
就能赚到惊人的利润
他们看的不是赢了几次
而是赢的时候能赢多少
这就是大赚小赔的真谛
那一旦理解了这一点
下一个问题自然就来了
道理我都懂
但我该如何做到大赚小赔
我怎么敢在看对的时候下大部位
对,这就是最难的地方
讲者说,很多人以为他敢下大柱
是因为他心脏比较大颗
偏身胆子大
对,但他澄清
这不是天生的胆量问题
而是他有一套方法
让自己可以止在对的时候
才让心脏变大颗
哦,这套流程很有智慧
他的做法是
在还不确定没有十足把握的时候
永远只用小部位进场去换感觉
换感觉这个词很有意思
我好像有点懂
你一定有过这种经验吧
刚下完单就觉得浑身不对劲
好像太急了
买早了
有喂 尝尝
这种感觉
无论你下小部位还是大部位都会出现
但差别在于
下大部位时
这种不对劲的感觉会让你痛到变形
影响你后续所有判断
完全正确
所以当感觉不对时
因为你只是小部位
停损出场根本不痛不痒
你就会敢于多方尝试
试了几次之后
总会遇到那么一次
是你下单之后感觉特别顺
特别有把握的时刻
那才是你真正该把部位加上去的时候
所以这整套流程
等于是把大部分的资金
都用在那些高把握度的刀口上
而不是耗损在每一次的频繁尝试中
正是如此
但这也引出了另一个很多人会遇到的问题
为什么我用小部位试单的时候
总是没感觉
啊对
亏了也不痛
就好像在玩游戏一样
根本学不到教训关于这点讲者有提出解释吗他有而且解释得非常直白他说因为你打从心底没把小钱当钱
他举例
当你月薪三万时
吃一顿三百块的午餐
你会觉得心痛
但当你月薪三百万时
同样三百块的午餐
你就完全没感觉了
不是食物变了
是你的心态变了
交易也是一样的
如果你不把小额的亏损
当成真正的亏损
你就永远学不到市场
透过这些小亏损
想交给你的事
没错
所以他提出一个听起来
非常反人性的训练方式
哦
这训练中是真的绝了
他说你要刻意练习
把赔钱的感觉放大
同时把赚钱的感觉缩小
等等
这听起来很违反直觉
一般人不都是
想办法麻痹亏损的痛苦
然后享受获利的快感吗
对 但他说那样是错的
你必须训练到
即使只是赔了300块
你都觉得非常痛苦
非常懊恼
你才会去认真检讨
下次才会更谨慎
反过来
当你赚了100万的时候
你要训练自己
能够平常心看待
告诉自己这只是数字
才不会因为过度兴奋
而得意忘形
做出错误的决策
对 也才能够冷静地抱住部位
让利润喷跑
这太有意思了
这是一种刻意的心理重塑
放大痛苦是为了让你对风险更敏感
缩小快乐是为了让你对利润更客观
最后笔记提到了
另一个杀伤力极大的心理陷阱
讲者说
拿同一张股票的走势图
在同一个价格拉回的点
不同的人会有完全相反的解读
这个我完全懂
以前我只要看到账户里的部位是红字
整个思考都僵住了
满脑子想的都是怎么解套
而不是客观地去想
现在这个价位还值不值得持有
完全一样
讲者分析
如果你是从低点买进一路报上来的
当你看到价格拉回
你的低反应可能是
涨时好像转弱了
是不是该获利了结了
但如果你是空手的人
错过了前面一整段涨幅
看到价格终于拉回
你可能会觉得
太好了
这是我上车的机会
而最惨的是第三种人
追高套在上面的人
当他看到价格拉回
他想的可能是
太好了
可以加码摊平降低成本了
同一个价格走势
三种完全不同的心态和决策
所以讲者做出结论
问题从来就不在行情本身
而在于你自己的资金杠杆部位和心理状态
你的部位决定了你的视角
真的
没错
所以他给出一个非常具体的建议
在盘中尽量不要去看你账户的浮动损益
也尽量不要一直盯着你的持股成本
因为这档股票在目前这个价位
还值不值得继续持有这个决策
跟你现在是赚是赔
没有任何逻辑上的关系
当你能把这两件事彻底分开
解开这个心结
你才能看到市场更真实的样貌
这真的需要大量的练习
才能摆涂成本和损益对决策的干扰
确实
好 今天我们从巨人节的这份演讲笔记中
可以说是一起走过了一趟从心派 逻辑 策略到执行的完整旅程
从一开始强调看对账单的可信度
到理解交易的本局是供需不平衡
接着是将公共新闻转化为私人策略
对 然后是放下对胜率的执着
专注于风险报酬比
以及如何透过流程来管理自己的部位与心态
整个听下来你会发现这些官面环环相扣
构成一个非常完整的交易哲学
他在笔记结尾时留下了一句很触动人的话
他说有时候撑着你的不是毅力也不是努力
而是一份单纯的喜爱
我见过真正成功的交易者
他们是真的热爱研究
享受与市场斗志的过程
对他们来说
那不是压力
而是一种无穷的乐趣和成长
这份喜爱
或许才是能够长期坚持下去的最终动力
而这也为正在收听的你
留下一个可以带回去思考的问题
当你下次看到一个市场热议的新闻或话题时
试着不要只当个旁观者或评论家
你可以练使用今天学到的框架问自己
这背后反映了什么样的工序变化
我能不能为此设计一个小小的
可以验证的策略
把它变成一个只属于我的机会
这是一个很棒的练习
把知识转化为行动
谢谢大家的聆听
如果有想听哪本书
可以在下面留言
谢谢大家
我们下次见